young people love love the books they
just said this is this very important
film to a lot of kids when you got the
call that this was gonna was a
possibility were you scared I believe I
think so what happened so fast I mean it
was a it it was this thing I finished
Hamilton and the next day well the next
day I took a train to DC and hosted a
poetry slam and then right after
finishing that hopped on a plane and
went to Vancouver to shoot so I had no
time to think about the fact that I was
doing something I'd never done before
and you know I I was terrified when I
got there for sure but I had that six
hour plane ride to let it sink in that I
had no idea what I was doing and but I
told the director that he took me out to
dinner the night that I landed I told
Stephen Chbosky that and he told me
later that that really calmed him down
he was like oh because he was very
nervous it was the first day of shooting
he was very nervous all of these kids
it's a cast full of kids he said he
heard that and said oh I've got to make
sure this is a really great day for
dahveed like well I found him and he it
worked whatever he did man it was it
felt super comfortable and super easy
and all of those kids are total pros so
I had a lot it was like all day I was
just asking advice from 11-year olds
which is not great for the ego but they
were very helpful and sometimes I find
that when you ask an 11-year olds like
how do you think I'm doing brutally
honest yeah oh yeah an 11-year olds has
no problem telling you yeah not great
you're a little force yes I'm not really
believing it right now but that's okay
they'll fix it in post well fix it in
post is a kid have a cigar will fix it
in both
some CGI in here all these give it I
liked it cause I didn't know like where
the cameras were kids are puffing away I
need a drink all right
you